[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it
in cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
in a good mood because we're going to
korean barbecue tonight there you go
that's nice you can go to a restaurant
everybody's been going to restaurants
is it popping out oh it's been popping
what we drive by earlier everybody was
out there well brett
la brea bro yeah what's up how you doing
people in texas right now i mean like
yeah [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] told your [ __ ] was gonna open
back up remember when we went there
and you know we tried we were trying to
go we tried coffee
they're like oh no can't get in nothing
nothing it is worse than here yeah
everyone talks about how lit texas they
need to come
they're pretty similar to l.a you guys
talking all that [ __ ] maybe it works
only florida's really florida's most
probably out of any state but it's still
not like not adorable atlanta atlanta
it's not normal oh sorry atlanta atlanta
is wide open wide open they've never had
them they never stopped
yeah they never stopped but florida they
don't get me wrong they're more open
than here hands down
but still not ready everyone needs to
chill out everyone hating on it
listen yeah our governor sucks the mayor
i get it
they're all [ __ ] but as far as like
lockdown you got the same as this
yeah it's not wide open but like new
york that's why schultz left and went to
miami because he's like i was talking to
him uh this morning
he's like dog out like new york grant
did they open up restaurants and stuff
like that he's like but yeah i realize
in new york it's freezing
so only outdoor dining is open nobody's
trying to eat outdoors who's trying to
say it's freezing
he's like so new york and he's like like
in l.a it gets colder but it's not like
snow and [ __ ] like yeah when you when
you're in quarantine you can still go to
the park and enjoy life
he's like here dude we're in apartments
he's like so it's like
art like even though we're like what if
let's say five's complete lockdown and
we're at like a two hours like it's
still like a five to us because we're
stuck in our [ __ ] apartments yeah
he's like that's why i went to miami i
get it i get it i get it miami or uh
miami right now but this comes out go
see brian callum tonight miami improv
yeah i do i mean [ __ ] i mean
do what you got to do [ __ ] i mean i get
why people want to move
dude if i didn't have kids and i was
like single young yeah i'd be in miami
i'd be in atlanta but also they got a
like i don't know you know
because i listened to your episode with
rogan like like
did you enjoy it yeah that's why you
said it like that why yes i enjoyed it
but it was just like austin is another
spot now we have another spot
yeah it's not what it is it's another
spot for comedy you know that not a l.a
though
it's not it's not early much is everyone
say oh it's gonna be better than
it stopped hey they're homeless they got
a lot of homeless there too
almost everywhere out there also it's a
blue state everyone chill the [ __ ] out
now what you guys do have is the the tax
break the tax break i'll give you that
i'll give you that yeah i'll do that
i'll give you that you got me on that
but you can't beat l.a
that weather the beaches the vibe the
creek
stand up once everything opens back up
okay yeah okay i've been still having
fun here
i'm still me too you know i mean i
haven't been like miserable or anything
i mean i don't have
there's been moments don't get me wrong
there's been moments where i've been
like damn like
2020 i went through some dark days yeah
i think everybody
attested yeah i have no friends left
they all get cancelled but the thing is
is gay new friends
yeah i don't know you guys that well
though goddammit
yeah chin's acting all different because
we're going to the [ __ ] korean
barbecue he finally talked me into it he
got the beanie off what's what's this
shave and [ __ ] manscape.com
what korean barbecue spirit we're going
to do we're going to place called
quarters
ooh and i told the staff out there where
we're going like oh that's the best it's
the best spot to get
all of it and uh jules nick's girlfriend
who just set up the bike yeah they just
went yesterday
and they had fun they loved it yeah is
that the one you told me that
we should go to on adults yeah that's
the first one we gotta go to
well you tell me yeah way before you
came in the picture
yeah here's the other thing's tricky
about i was gonna invite you guys with
your ladies we never see you outside the
studio we tried
sixes yeah oh yeah oh yeah they did say
that yeah
but who's but also at the same time who
trying to go to dinner in a [ __ ]
group yeah
is
what are they going to do for the super
bowl now what do you say is now parties
everyone's going to have no no there's
party
everybody play everybody but our [ __ ]
uh mayor garcetti the biggest place in
the world
is like trying like if you're gonna have
a party you need to do this leave your
mask on
it's like shut up yeah baby yeah yeah
and no outdoor tvs which is lame because
we want to get together at restaurants
and watch
people people have a better chance
everybody's gonna do it bro
people probably have a better chance of
getting it in a group in their house
than they do
at an outdoor restaurant with science
yeah they right lockdowns within when
you're
in the they realize it spreads it more
yes you're at home
like around the family if you can't go
out and you're just crazy like we have
like this
strictly sauce but like the most cases
yeah i hate the mask though i hate the
mask
i hate the mad situation when you it's
required to go in and you forget the
mask
and you gotta go all the way back to
your car you feel like you're my
favorite you immediately take it off as
soon as you sit down
my favorite are the guys that you know
when they forget the last thing oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna try doing this i basically
yeah yeah can i get a number two and uh
and the
guy's like not doug but i'm with him
like how's the city different you're
right
because i know exactly what they're
doing going through they're all [ __ ]
like all right watch this
like can i get a venti a bear bryant
they're like no they don't do it
you don't want to go back to that car i
got to go back all the way to my car
and uh where is this uh korean barbecue
place out where am i meeting you at it's
in the heart of cape town there's like a
fiscal challenge as far as cape town
from downtown from downtown it's like 15
minutes
how far would it take me to get to that
ceso hotel from there i want to just
drive
by it's very close i think is this safe
for me to drive by in my car oh yeah
yeah
cecil hotel is yeah really yes but in
that skid row though
yeah skid road is open yeah i don't want
homeless all over my car like walking
don't do that
i don't know i mean correct me correct
me if i'm wrong don't quote me on this
but i heard like they have like uh
there's like what you know kind of like
leaders
oh yeah oh yeah like if like if they if
like people go drop stuff off at skid
row you gotta check in
he's gotta check shock you could drop it
off but the shot caller's got to
check everything and he has a gun he
assigns he has a gun
oh he does yeah oh yeah i've been
listening to some leaders yeah yeah
so my my my brother's girl was his baby
mom she worked down there for like skid
row so we always used to go down there
and pick her up
got it right so by the way it was one
thing she's working like medical or
i think she just like helped them out
with food got it like okay that kind of
purpose yeah yeah
so we like we pulled over and then you
know we're trying hey bro you got
something to eat for us
and it was he was by himself so i was
like what do you mean so i was alright
bro i gave him some chips and stuff like
that he's like appreciate you og
let me know if you need anything and he
showed me his gun i was like
oh he means that you saved yeah yeah
and like even if you are homeless like
you can't just stay there you gotta you
gotta own your kids
it's like they gotta jump you gotta
bring something yeah you gotta bring
something to the table yeah it was it
was a
what's your skill set skill set do you
have mouthwash you got mouthwash
oh you know soap are you know a baddie
you know a baddie you've got
water yeah
i always think about how would they fix
that what do you mean they just got to
let it be huh
the skid row yeah it's too deep now
but yeah to your point though yeah
austin they don't have a skid row but
there's homeless like scared oh bro
remember
we saw the dude just shooting up under
the freeway it was like a
like a like an encampment yeah under the
this bridge
where it's free so i'm shooting up meth
uh here we are locking it up bro
right right because they had a little
little the you know those like
port-a-potty sinks yeah
they had that right out there and it was
it was like all these cars
you guys would stop there and just saw
him shooting up no i wasn't gonna stop
that the light
yeah it was like a new jack city kind of
thing we were we were on our way to get
you and we were stopped at a light
and we just saw like it was just a big
encampment that's fun
i know it was it was pretty cool action
yeah yeah a little action i was like
okay they talk like a live
first 48. it's just dope it's just funny
how people talk all this [ __ ] though
about l.a and i'm like
i talked to emily from the store this
morning because i did ryan sickler's
podcast for this oh yeah uh honeydew
shout out to
and um she was saying that the la jolla
is gonna probably they're gonna start
booking comics in march
oh hell yeah okay good see bruh
something he's gonna be patient yeah he
might be half capacity but i don't give
a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
i had an epiphany right no i should say
i had an idea right i think
big difference yeah big difference
that's why someone had yeah cecil hotel
yeah all of us book a room no okay cool
keep going okay all of us book a room
films it jim
like films
and late at night and just like just sit
there like all of us in the room and
then we go back to that
separate good idea yeah you see what i'm
saying from there podcast from the
seasonal hotel all of us
we're booking room hey listen i know a
girl who uh like is in hotels look like
the suite there
we all stay the night like snuggle up
bro we ain't gotta do
that [ __ ] what are you talking about i'd
be down thank you bro come on
i'm pretty sure cat is down chin are you
down let me grab my hair i'll take it to
richard ramirez
why are we just putting ourselves in a
situation because we want it to happen
thank you what's gonna happen anything
that's gonna happen is gonna be on
camera
chin is filming two hours in just
podcasting i don't know how i sleep
i'm not staying tonight when you get
back to sleep it's getting worse bro
come on no but also i'm dead
yeah listen no one needs to just be
putting this up in situations all right
we've already done that type of [ __ ] in
our life where we just put ourselves in
[ __ ] up situations yeah we're a little
old now
yeah we're over there i'll be down
though again okay thank you
i thought he was with me i thought i had
shins down
oh yeah i bet you they do oh there's a
debunked video of that
uh the girl the asian girl oh someone
debunked it someone you looked into it
or someone sent it to you it was sent to
me well i mean what happened it happened
but this
like some of the details were different
somebody said that happened but some of
the details that people were saying
like what um there was easy access for
her to get in that watch oh really
yeah that's i was thinking about on the
drive here i don't know why i'm so into
like the nights like
right about like i have like two books
on the nightstalker i watched the movie
documentary i watched
it
yeah i don't know why i'm into it but
then also when you think his there's no
conspiracy with him
right with him it's just flat out there
with like the manson family there's a
ton of conspiracies with this there's
conspiracies
sometimes in jfk there's conspiracies i
believe that one
but some conspiracies are usually funner
than the truth i think that's why they
catch so much like
hype because they're way funnier than
the truth yeah because like with jfk
being shots like yeah crazy dude henry
uh
oswald shot him when it's like that end
of story
then people like nah man i think this
and then you go through all the
different scenarios it's way funner
manson you know they would just give him
a record deal would have killed him
he would have just got a record just
gave him a record maybe
also he could have broken ground be like
[ __ ] it i'm going independent
i don't know but there wasn't there
wasn't that option because radio was a
big thing
back in the day like you know the radio
everything it was everything it was like
oh you're
you're the [ __ ] dude if the beach
boys didn't [ __ ] him over yeah
because they took his song right took
your song put it on one song right
more than one but more than one one word
for word and just didn't give him any
credit
damn but also i would like to if let's
say it was back then you could go back
in time i'll just sit down charles
manson like
this whole which the elder skelter uh
narrative i don't believe
let's say it was real i'm like hey this
whole helter skelter thing
you think by killing these white people
and then
uh trying to make it look like the black
panthers did you really think that's
going to
start a race war is that what he was
trying to actually die
i'm like yeah stupid you gotta come with
someone else that's not gonna work dude
you're not gonna work right it's a
terrible idea
like how does no one just like man i'm
down for the cause bro
it seems stupid this idea is dumb as
[ __ ] yeah you don't think they're gonna
figure it out
like there's better ways to go about it
yeah but black people don't slaughter
people like that
no no yeah and then it doesn't make
sense like dude it doesn't make sense
to go nationwide and then yeah and then
you think black people are gonna revolt
and then like come at us and and then
you're gonna go to a hole and stay
underground while this revolt's
happening and come out
that's the whole you visited yeah like
it's like yeah it's like you know stupid
this is dude
you know insane the sounds but his
followers were all on like ass and lsd
and they thought he was the [ __ ]
second coming of jesus christ y'all ever
done acid
no no that's why i draw the line really
cause when i was a kid there's a rumor
going around probably a lie now
but some girl in my town i'm sure every
town has this girl
did acid and then thought she was an
orange and started peeling her skin like
an orange
at first i don't know i hear so
away from it it definitely scared me
away because just when you think about
it logistically like
you can't peel your skin like an orange
no matter how high you remember no
matter how high
it was eating yeah
yeah oh i remember that what was that
[ __ ] it was like 2012.
he ate that pretty sure the the black
dude that guy's face his face
remember that [ __ ] yeah that really
happened that's what i'm saying and then
they they even tried to like
who was shot him and he wasn't even
moving who was selling bath salt on the
street stuff first of all what the [ __ ]
listen yeah you could probably get a bad
batch of lsd but i know so many people
that do it in
lsd that is like the acid and [ __ ] like
that
and i've never heard them talk any
anything crazy a lot i know a lot of
people that do it asap rocky got a song
about lsd so
i don't think i don't think it's as
crazy as people say it is to be i'm
still not gonna do it
you don't have to i'm not to do it bro
you know how insane you're trying to
do shrooms and stay at that [ __ ] ciso
hotel have you done shrimp
i have micro dose yeah oh micro dose
yeah never the real thing so wait are
you
are you we talk everyone's gonna be
sober we gotta like feel the experience
live the experience i'm not trying to do
this me and jim probably have some
whiskey
you kiss my own so you're making a vibe
okay dude i had to get
up i did i have a nurse come to the
house for health insurance
bro they go through everything
everything
heavy they check your blood pressure
your heart rate
ekg oh my urine
your weight height uh then they go
obviously you know they're like
do you drink like nope not at all like
you have no drinks i've had one drink
and then she's i go i have one drink a
month and she's like all that whiskey's
for once a month i'm like
she's like you do know tobacco i'm like
nope never and then just around my house
is all these [ __ ]
things bro yeah that's not as strong as
uh
like skull huh no [ __ ] no that school
[ __ ] that [ __ ] made me puke when i was a
kid
yeah me too i don't [ __ ] with that stuff
yeah you don't [ __ ] with that
yeah health insurance is weird it is
brother uh
yeah like if i if i'm riding my bike and
get hit right like they go through all
the dangerous [ __ ] everything
everything cars everything yeah how long
you drive to work everything
yeah you need it it is expensive you
need it [ __ ] huh no
it's really hot oh yours isn't expensive
no so there's oh so there's there's ways
to find cheaper insurance for sure
who are you with huh who are you with
[ __ ] medi-cal oh
but you're talking about straight health
insurance yeah yeah life insurance
yeah yeah it's a difference
my health is expensive as [ __ ] with two
young ones for the whole family
life insurance yeah i just got hip to
that it was like yeah no i yeah i
uh when my brother died i got uh he made
me the beneficiary
for his life insurance oh so what'd you
get 75 grand
oh damn me ballin but i hated it no yeah
you don't oh yeah i did i didn't i did
not like it i hated it
the whole [ __ ] it's like the george
floyd family i think they got like
12 million everyone's like oh man they
must be so happy like
you know i'm miserable bro i tell people
this because like what i did with it
you know to say five grand yeah i just
started helping people
anyone and anyone and everybody i just
started helping people with all all the
money
this was uh he died in 2013 and that was
2004 and i was 2000 it was 2014 when i
got it
and seven years ago yeah and it was i
mean it was the biggest struggle every
time i looked at my account and like
i was just going through it so heavy
like that was probably the lowest point
of my life was like you know after my
brother had died
and so like having all that money it was
just like i was like man you know i
could get 75 grand again
but i can't get him back so i was just
like let me just feel kind of like dirty
right
you can't enjoy it yeah you can't enjoy
and the thing that was wild though was
like
i felt better oh for sure helping people
and it wasn't like i was just like i
need to help people like i was trying to
do
someone's struggling yeah yeah it was
just like oh if i saw it
i'd react and it would just be like here
here's this yeah so that's just what i
did with that that's cool
yeah i'll get 75 grand again yeah yeah
ain't there yet but you're good
you're close close yeah i'm on my way
yeah i'm on my way up
but no yeah it's i mean yeah that life
insurance [ __ ] like yeah because
it's like you're like yeah like talking
on the phone with these people it's like
this normal conversation to them but i'm
like no it's heartbreaking oh yeah it's
so heartbreaking i'm like i don't even
know
when i went to the bank you know they
were you know like because they know
what's up like they they have these
checks come in
you know or like when people come in and
like you know set up these
accounts it's so so heavy so like i
i mean i felt better after hell yeah and
people thought i was crazy for like
getting rid of it like that but i'm like
man i don't think i don't know like yeah
you you may have enjoyed it you know
some people may have enjoyed it some
people probably would have
you know done something different with
it or whatever but i don't know i just
couldn't do it that way
yeah i can't do it i wish my grandfather
had like life insurance when he passed
away
oh you didn't no your grandfather yeah
people don't have too much
my uncle passed away the most successful
dude i knew
i knew passed away with like millions of
million men so i was like oop
here we go
and my dad well my dad made his will too
they left me
nothing but i was not you good now
you're good
all right am i though am i
you got it now wait what what is your uh
big time
uh i forgot what i was gonna ask that's
crazy though crazy what are you guys
doing for the super bowl
uh watching it go versus brady uh i
don't know
i honestly don't know watching the game
i guess you're watching the game
yeah yeah this is a big game we i'm
betting it is a big game
my girls my girl's gonna fire up the
fryer make her
classic wings i know you want to come
over doug come on
down come on down like that i like i
remember when i dropped you off i was
like hey dog
that fryer she didn't do it she's gonna
do it and do it
what kind of would have the lemon pepper
the wet lemon pepper i love the hot no
we don't [ __ ] with dry never drive i
like yeah
i'm not i'm not i don't like a person
i'm not drunk driving dope driveway
dry rub yeah driver yeah i like it yeah
that meat's really good
it is but that wet damn jake i know you
like to get wet
what you mean it's angel dustin this
angel does one of the best
yeah the wet wings come on nothing
better
nah i'm gonna fire those up yeah the
lemon pepper the barbecue she makes like
this uh whiskey barbecue sauce
and then uh hot it's me fresh
yeah she does be making her own sausage
oh yeah is it hot is it spicy what is it
like
it's hot hot sauce oh yeah she know how
to get that spice
yeah she did oh that's oh yes she knows
how to get that kick to it man
so frito i'm remembering this mexican i
used to know she made this sofrito sauce
the empanadas
empanadas so freedom let me let me see
that uh korean barbecue spot we're going
to yeah let's yeah let me see this let's
see if i can get here you want to go to
the up one
uh uh whatever has to be mentioned any
menu from the
restaurant wherever you look is that
what you do is go to yelp yeah yeah
you get to do something but here's the
sucky part yeah you should i am going to
have it tonight because i can't [ __ ]
i know
with you guys what sucks is like we
would have a grill like this
and there would be cheese on top right
here that you dip your meat into
and into the sauce however since it's
outdoors they might give us those little
outdoor grills you know the ones that
like propane like the portables yeah
really that's thing it sucks brendan
never got to experience
real like korean barbecue that i wanted
to do first to go to seattle which
or was it seattle somewhere seattle
which that's not known for korean bbq
right
no and then now finally he's going to
come to quarters but we can't get the
grill
it's not the full area the food man the
meat on that grill
i don't know what the [ __ ] it is i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on
but crazy high quality [ __ ] is it
high high quality and
and it's just the the is it one price
per like person is that how they do it
no no it's not like that this is more
it's it's designed to like
there's a meet menu there's a pork menu
and there's combos we'll do a combo
you'll do the comments yeah i wish i
remember that one bobby lee took it i
would do
i think it's okay that's it yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i just said it that's advanced too so
the three top ones in
l.a is kangaroo quarters
and agashi gupta yep where's
they're all in the same area yeah
they're uh it's on eighth street right
or sixth street yeah one of those one
one of those streets it's either sixth
or eighth street but man
they give you a coyote yup this oh
that's just good
was that cheese [ __ ] egg say your
queso
egg yeah i'm telling you you wait to eat
it though
look at that malik you be picky
yeah there's a lot of goodness well you
like it can i forget why did you come to
seattle with us
we're doing the neptune theater i think
down there i forgot
i mean i would just go to shows every
now and then that's true yes that means
hang out
look at that yeah but see look at the
meat tonight
the meats are just super high quality
that's a skirt you don't like it
yeah i've never been that big of a
what what's that rice i did a food truck
on tuesday or monday
and they had i've never had ramen i've
had like ramen noodle when you're yeah
but they had a ramen truck that [ __ ] was
fantastic
yeah pork belly a pork belly yeah
it was nice you know i haven't i haven't
had ramen in a minute because
um there was like no when the dining
wasn't
able to happen because when you order
ramen it's just it's
not the same it's soggy because they
have they have i mean it's separate
separated from the oh there it is shake
ramen
this is what you had the the one yeah
that one
this one yep that's it that [ __ ] was
that [ __ ] went hard in the paint it was
nice
bro i love food we're talking a lot
about food man
yeah that [ __ ] was fire see i'm i'm i
can eat like meal preps every day and
don't
and won't complain like uh i had every
day of the week i had teriyaki chicken
rice and broccoli that sounds funny yeah
every day though every day
for every meal every meal and like i'll
do that though like i've been on a pat
thai kick lately i've had patches oh
yeah yeah you've been getting down on
that past time
you got introduced to it no i've no oh
no no i've been known
had it for years i just love pad thai
yeah they shake it they put a top on it
and they shake it that's a cool concept
it's tasty man
wait so what state again b they put a
top so they put all
you add like whatever you want to add
and then they put a top on it you can
show you as far as you want just to mix
it all up
like a boba it's really nice you like
the egg like no i don't get egg you
don't get the egg no i don't like eggs
with your
i expect you to say that i expect
different from you i don't like egging
my soup
oh yeah that looks good come on yeah it
was nice chin you'd like it yeah
i used to have to shoot a show for
comedy central it's
i think it drops end of march it's the
best of uh the rose
roast yeah so we i wrote all these jokes
for the cause you're supposed like
jokes and stories and whatever and chime
in on all the best skits
dude two hours i thought it was just me
an hour and i had about 45 minutes of
material
after about 60 minutes i went yo hold on
can we stop filming for a second
how long are we doing this they said two
hours i'm like what comic has two hours
of roast material
oh it's like tom oh he's a beast it is
tough i had it
we had to do the uh to a certain point
it was just me like being like oh that
was funny you know like
yeah you don't know what to say
i got an hour material man this is it
yeah
i gave you everything i had and then
he's like oh we're we're fast on timers
so we're gonna do extra clips i'm like
i don't know if you notice man i'm out
of energy they don't even realize it oh
they don't care because i had to do it
with the e network for that
show i did the dating note filter where
we just like roast these dates or
whatever
it's tough we were there it's 12 hour
day just sitting and we had to watch
like
i think five dates after out of five
like
you know sorry ten i came out to get hot
like i said 45 an hour where they got
they're gonna be able to cut that up
dope dicey funny stuff after that man i
was like
her her outfit's cool man
how long will you do this yeah yeah
charlie sheen is cool yeah
i was like two hours i like his movies
tiger blood two hours man
that's tough bro anything with that's
why movies just movie sets
12-hour days it's a lot of sitting
around just not
doing anything wait how long were you on
set for that one you did with the
oh charlotte bus uh three days
three days 12 hour days uh longer than
that yeah my call time was like 6am i'd
leave at like
midnight sometimes [ __ ] actually not for
me
no huh unless you do it like this it was
like a buddy comedy movie and all my
boys didn't we
we like wrote it and all yeah that's
different like the kids 3d which we did
which is like
10 like short episodes they're like 30
minutes long like me and callum wrote
that we knew everything like yeah we'd
start at seven eight we just wanted to
show midnight yeah we had fun
man yeah before you came on hunting yeah
it was before this is so funny i watched
it so fun
so funny oh work i talked to brian
today's in uh miami
miami miami yeah miami probably i don't
know
that's what he said oh he did wait would
you do like a would you be like a guest
star on a tv show
i would never say never i i think so you
know i don't know yeah i don't know
like if uh i just feel like the dope tv
show modern family hitting them
well like no i like yellowstone maybe i
don't know
if you did like a yellow stone they just
have to be something funny that's going
to help push
funny yeah i'd have to push what i'm
doing we're funny
if i play like a serious dude it'd be
tough blackish i'd love to see you on
blackish
a lot of mexican roles that's so funny
that would be a funny episode just on
black is you the new neighbor that moved
in
and yeah everybody they don't know it
was like what is it and i wonder if tv
money is the same like it used to be
yeah
you see the housekeeping yeah still
there you see the house kevin james the
spot
from king and queens it's crazy dog
bring that [ __ ] up chin kevin james from
that king queen money well
kings and queen jewels that he's getting
king of queens fourteen
dollars and that's all off of king of
oh [ __ ] what monster bruh him and rogan
are really close
too many [ __ ] windows but yeah it
looks like a hotel
yeah i couldn't do with all the windows
but damn that countertop
right where is this at florida
florida del rey beach 14 mil out there
son
i couldn't live in florida but damn look
at that look at the ocean in your
backyard
i could this is my thing like i could
live in texas i could live in florida
when you have that kind of money once
once you're done like kevin james is
done
yeah and you realize i don't know when
people realize kevin james stand up
when he was young [ __ ] sad
dude that's broken about ron's like oh
dude he'd suck the air out of the room
some of the best bits you've ever seen
damn
but then you know then he was on king
and queens and was like all right yeah
i'm out
yeah he did a special netflix but he
hasn't been in the game you know been in
a game game like that
he would he would tour no i went through
i went to bed last night watching uh
earthquake oh he's a legend
oh my god i was waking my girl up i was
laughing at her like
[ __ ] like midnight i could and i was
so tired but it came on i was going
to watch this he has the best delivery
yo he's so do you watch his uh serious
xm he has like funny comics on it oh he
has a serious excellent show yeah
quake house he's so [ __ ] funny yeah
you went old school though
it was on show time and i was like let
me and then they were like all right now
come to stage earthquake
i was like i'll watch this before i go
back to you i always watch first 48
before i go to bed
that's what that's horrible it's dark
yeah then i was like i'll switch to this
so i switched because i watched a
nightstalker thing and i watched first
48 i was he's too heavy
so i saw this as on i was great let me
see the earthquake dude he was so
[ __ ] he's a monster
[ __ ] funny he comes he come up with
that class with the bernie max
the uh oh yeah yeah he's got a dope
class he came up with
lavell crawford he's a very funny guy oh
he's super funny you know the big fat
guy yeah
yeah he's talking about he's talking
about he about uh you can tell how old
school this is
because he was on there too i think it
was a shaquille o'neal comedy night in
florida
and oh okay yeah yeah so went him for
like 10 15 20 minutes then it went
uh was what's the other guy's name uh uh
lavell crawford
crawford lavell came out he's talking
about because obama just got elected
and he was saying how he bought obama uh
shirt and
of course he didn't fit so i had to cut
it down the middle yes he said i rolled
up this barbecue it was like damn
we get a little obama vest on it
he's like he's like this shit's
exclusive
it's exclusive
[Laughter]
hey you know you know what's crazy about
bruce bruce he's so famous when he does
shows he has to pay
people to like yo if you want to take a
picture with him you have to pay him
because it's they won't leave they won't
leave they won't leave
they won't leave he was like man he's
just so famous him and ricky smalley
those church going people they will stay
let me get a picture and they
stayed there they got them dying he was
like bro i got another show you have to
pay me now and then so you get paid
him yeah ricky smiley oh yeah he's he's
master oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's blew off on a bit yeah yeah uh but
he does
he he does a lot of uh he's he does a
lot of church stuff though yeah yeah
yeah he does he doesn't like he's a
comic he's a clean cop yeah which like
that church market
must be tough man i couldn't do it it's
a marketplace for me
it's a market you watched my set the
other day for for this project
i'm doing and i was like i cut so much i
cussed a lot man
i know but yeah i think we can do it but
it's just like the mental clean yeah
yeah be tough because let's say you do
like yo jimmy fallon's like hey brandon
can you do a late night
yeah you clean that up it's just a
mental thing it's not that i watch it it
is
it's just fun yeah it's a curse i used
to roll with frank i used to roll with
frank caliendo and he uh
that was the first time i ever like
learned how to like work clean
yeah yeah you have to with him yeah it's
a skill it's it's definitely it's good
it's a definitely
skill i think i think when i curse it
just escape because i couldn't curse a
lot
around my parents sometimes they say
cursing is like
it's the easy way out it is your boy uh
earthquake drops the end bomb
yeah yeah but no honestly if you listen
to this
god dawg well look you guys like bernie
mac too bernie mac
oh yeah i'm not scared of your muffler
he made up a bit kick it but i'm saying
i'm saying earthquake he doesn't do that
now
he doesn't say the n-word doesn't ah he
just he cuz
he's on t like listen if you want to
blow up you can't say that that that's
what they
yeah but that's what they tell you back
then that's old school
back then maybe yeah yeah chris tucker
doesn't stand up
he doesn't cuss no more nope he changed
yeah he's doing churches on [ __ ]
is he really you know he turned down uh
the friday the front in the new movie
friday here's i'm not coming back
because
that character that i played in friday
i'm not the same guy
that i am now and i don't want my new
artist they're trying to do it now yeah
he said he was on uh shannon sharp i
watched that on this podcast yeah right
yeah he blew up he blew up after that
friday movie right because
he went russian yeah well yeah hey 10
grand 10 grand
i know he's complaining but it's us like
you know but they didn't know it was
going to blow yeah they didn't know
if you just read the headline where it
says 10 grand like come on man but no
like for the next day
before next friday i heard they couldn't
afford him no he demanded he imagined
that
you're right we'll give mike epps a shot
yeah and you know how
you found cat williams too how do you uh
stand up right yep in the club so ice
cream
back chilling and he was like yo who was
the name yeah no no i'm talking about
mike
yeah so uh he was like yo i want you to
audition for my movie
and he was like all right he didn't know
he's i never act before and then during
their
you know you have your table reads are
there's screen tests he had
ice cube dying he could not all of a
sudden and that's how mike
he's so funny yes there's one special
from 09
uh never faded
he was on a podcast and he was saying
like yo this how he knew he wanted to be
a comedian
because he was like got kidnapped right
the guy's like he owed the drug dealers
money
and they put him in the back of the
trunk and he was like man they about to
kill me and all that
so he was like this is how i knew i was
going to be a comedian when they hit a
bump
and he knocked on the back he's like hey
hey that's like what you want
he was like hey play that again that's
my song
because i didn't let this funny
[ __ ] monster that's dope yeah
you know
he was uh actually banned from stand up
live for a minute why
because uh yeah some okay so it was uh
and the videos on youtube do get the so
so
i guess someone heckled him right and i
guess mike epps rolls with like a squad
like he got goons with the crew
and uh some dude was heckling him i
think mike has
my caps was handling it or whatever but
i think his boys
were like took their [ __ ] to the heart
seriously they
beat the [ __ ] out of this dude in that
club
bad like was beating him with like the
chairs and [ __ ]
hold on go to uh spears why do you call
her spears i mean everybody call up
where is it
so it's uh stand up live or show you
some mic ups it was that
uh stand up by phoenix phoenix try that
i'm talking about mike you thought the
mic might be high
oh they probably took it off it was it
was it was a bad beating
to do uh well [ __ ] he was about to get
the fight at the j-spot out here
in my case in compton right now i was in
uh
on um uh cincinnela you ever go to
j-spot
was performing i was performing and it
was like a black knight you had my caps
you had uh
who else was there uh what's the guy
who'll be killing the black old school
comic
there's a lot of kills heckler oh d-ring
can [ __ ] murder hecklers oh
especially women
oh yeah oh my god he waits for a woman
he went after that
the lesbian oh in the crowd
he was like shut up while i make your
parents happy now oh yeah
i'll
[Laughter]
and he just does bits yeah d-rays are
killer oh
carlos miller killer as well he's a
[ __ ] yeah yeah
okay okay brendan alone a lot of black
comments yeah i see you
yeah you went to the hurricane huh fell
asleep listening to her
yeah i'm sorry earthquake perfect i'm
like i love
follow him
shoot everybody
and he came back with the gun came back
with that gun that's a good movie yeah
you know what i love i love everybody
but he's like
with uh woody harrelson it's all like
[ __ ] what's it i forget what heroes and
characters oh what is this
how the [ __ ] you know you have a kid
yeah yeah he was
both you're all weird
both y'all weird i love that movie
that's the [ __ ] movie though i was
watching life last night
was good oh come on clawed
dude life is [ __ ] legendary
it's so it's so many hidden gems in
there like you just still find stuff
that's funny when it was like pulled up
to that spot where they was jamming to
get the wine
and he was like we're looking for slim
no that not that one chin how dare you
jen
he wants to like the breath how did that
movie did you do you watch a lot of
black movies
the ones that you guys mentioned before
you've seen life though right
i don't think i've seen like oh
[Music]
you got a lot of black friends though
chin right honestly i have one
actually one close black okay you kept
it real jen yeah i'm being honest
i mean you guys obviously but i'm like
posting it he's got him terrance but
he's very white
he's terrance yeah he likes metal too oh
is he from texas
no he's from uh i think arizona
oh my arizona might be he's here now i'm
not sure i've never asked him where he's
actually from oh he's your age though
yeah uh have you have you seen that
coming to america too
yeah they've gone out yet it's not out
you know they have a trailer
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's like a little
it looks all right yeah i was about to
offer
stuff when they're older men
oh yeah [ __ ] that that's kind of this
feels a little bit the same vibe
it's too old i hate when it goes it's
too long well hold on
what do you mean it's too long meg the
stallion in there no she's not that's
what they said
they figure out who shot her foot you
got her in there too leslie jones yeah
you got uh jermaine fowler
he's a comic right yeah yep very funny
he's a new york comic uh he came out
that area new york comedy but he's out
here now
do they have a lot of the original cast
members for this well yeah they're still
alive
um they have rotimi in there they have
dc on fly in there
i wonder if uh they could have got
brendan schaub up in there oh yeah
i wonder if eddie murphy's still gonna
do his stand-up stuff he's special that
quiet down a little bit
well yeah i think with cove and stuff
he's like i can't tour [ __ ] that
yeah yeah they got rotimi they got kiki
lane she's a cool yeah
i would love to see him do stand up
everyone's like oh he'll be back i mean
give him a [ __ ] chance
i just it's just different though man
it's different like like took that long
of a break
yeah we already know you know he's still
funny yeah he's still funny but he's not
like you you watch him in interviews
like he just
yeah you know he has a barbecue like
every [ __ ] weekend at his house who
kevin hart no no
kevin hart he's always got a party kevin
hart was like dude he's the funniest
person in the room
every time he was like he's like every
time i see him i he he finally told me
to shut the [ __ ] up he's like dude every
everyone tells me
dude stand up and he's like dude you
guys need to shut the [ __ ] up
damn well jeff garland said the same
thing about that like jeff grolling
uh for those who don't know did a movie
with eddie murphy with uh daddy daycare
yeah they did daddy
every time every time he was like bro he
always had a joke ready
eddie will always stump him like to beat
him to the punch with the funnier yeah
he's like just a natural funny comic
that's what i'm saying i'm like i think
he i think he'd be [ __ ] great
i don't think he'd come back and like
ruin his reputation no i don't care i
don't think you and i think
i think that's why he took a break what
that that's why i think he
he's not doing stand-up right now he's
like i can't tour like a regular
comic i'm gonna wait they were still on
a half ass they were saying like
he got to a point that he was so big
yeah that i mean
that he would go do a show and people
would just shout shout
yeah so like it was just like probably
even in theaters right oh yeah yeah
he was just getting you i mean it's
[ __ ] martin stopped doing stand-up
he's a beast yeah he stopped doing it
because people just keep shouting old
bits
yeah and then like stuff would mess up
that was supposed to be that
it would like ruin the bit but people
would still laugh real hard he's like oh
i'm [ __ ]
damn he's like i don't know what's funny
anymore because everything i do imagine
being too big to do a [ __ ] statement
then you just you just do movies now
that's that's your name
yeah [ __ ] next what'd you say you do
movies yeah
i mean movie money's still big
my friend on dear white people gets paid
a million dollars an episode what
what yeah that's like make that thing on
that you're white people that's that's
tv show i'm talking about movie money
movies the same way movie but unless
you're a big boy you're not really
making too much that's what i'm saying
i don't imagine if you're not a big
movie star i don't i doubt you're making
that much
oh he's uh he's the guy who plays uh
lionel yeah with the glasses i think
your friends are lying to you
well i mean i think your friend's line
then that's fine
where did you say it let me [ __ ] stop
when you learn
dear white people yeah dear white people
uh big bang theory
they were making they were making like a
million episodes i gotta call them man
i'm like bro they saying you're lying
about your uh
dear white people actor quits netflix
show amid pay
discrimination oh a lot of people got it
laid off yeah he told me about that
but again covet times and stuff like you
right yeah your friend oh yeah everybody
if they play friends and you know what
it's not a big deal but he's
he's not even on the show yeah that was
very strange he lied to me
yeah but it's fun to talk like that type
in the ron horton network let me just
see whatever happens
yeah horde net worth those are those
aren't accurate
even not the accurate one let's see but
if he makes it per episode you know and
that's his entire net worth i don't
think
so okay all right um but again it's fun
to talk like that
you know my girl and i were watching uh
jay and silent bob last night that's a
great movie and it was hard to enjoy she
got too woke for it
i was like oh are you serious i was like
let this be where it was but
she was upset about it no she wouldn't
have said she was just like pointing out
every i was like oh
that kills the move yeah yeah i realized
the timing was made
i was like shut up yeah leave it at 99
what was it
99 at least i was never a first one fan
of their theirs i love i like that movie
it was
i i thought it was a great movie it has
like a [ __ ] cult following
nah yeah they came up with a second one
i
did yeah like kevin strike back straight
back they did
strike oh 2001 yeah what do you expect
it to be in 2001.
see what's happening in two thousand
well it's like uh 911. you know what so
you know so weird is we were talking
about uh cordell stewart somewhere how
he got accused of being gay remember the
guy who goes
i don't like men's anymore yeah he said
he hooked up with cordell andre
they had to pay cordell 10 million court
for whatever reason cordell in the
players tribune wrote an article this
morning
about that about that are you saying oh
[ __ ] yeah it was dope he was saying how
uh you know he was a baller people don't
realize how good he was
yeah and he was like when that came out
and he was like
as i'm writing this article realize i'm
i'm talking
you got to realize the times i'm talking
about you're talking about 1998 1999
and he's like you know being gay in that
in that locker room
like [ __ ] people aren't woke like they
are now like yeah and
he was like especially i'm a stern
quarterback for [ __ ]
the steelers the steelers the blue
collar town like
being gay super frowned upon and he's
like like fans were
calling me the f-word non-stop he was
like because of that dude yeah he was
like he was like the darkest time ever
bro he ruined his life and plus he was
he was saying he had to um
he had to um get the team like the
uh the coach so he went and talked to
his coach bill cower and his coach was
crying
he's like yo you know this isn't real
like this is all made up
like this isn't real dude i'm not gay
gosh that yeah and he was like he was
just a different time
that kind of [ __ ] makes me mad and they
do that and then he goes he goes think
about weird
different timings he goes they made me
address the team and tell the team i
wasn't gay
and he goes imagine if a twitter rumor
started some
quarterback now yeah they would never
put any energy into it
ever he's like you would never have to
address it to the team but at that time
that he was in and so then the owner of
team rooney
uh did some investigating and it started
from a cop
it started from a cop spreading the
rumor a cop spread of the other one and
then you know this pittsburgh kind of a
small town so it went around everywhere
and he transferred and then he goes and
then one of his uh so he's like man i
just want you guys know like you know
what i do like i'm about chicks and blah
blah
and he said the whole team was like yeah
i guess no one believed him he didn't
mention
the teammate's name one of the teammates
went up to his like hey man i want you
to know
whether you're gay whatever it is i
don't care he's like i like you as
cordell i don't give a [ __ ]
what you do in your half time and he
said he blew up on the guy he's like i
feel a bad thing about it now
but he was he was doing the right thing
he was yeah
like he was we don't care what you are
it's all good 100 what you do behind
closed doors is your business i support
you
yeah and he said he lashed out at him
was like you think i'm gay man he's like
no i don't care what you are i don't
care
don't tell me it's just it's just it's
just when you read it you're like yeah
it sucks that people don't realize like
how easy they can
[ __ ] up someone's [ __ ] like this goes
for anything that people just say about
a person
and like how easy especially a person
that's a celebrity
you know what i mean like it just i
don't know i think it's just trash when
people do [ __ ] like that cardell's girl
porsche
poor we see her all the time porsha is
bad so the fact that you know bad
kids too yeah that's kids so the fact
that he saw probably saw this guy
probably saw cardio
on housewives or whatever it is and made
up a lot i saw him in the mall
it's just it's just messed up but yeah
and how quick people like
porsha came out she spoke oh that's
porsha from uh real housewives oh
okay and she spoke up for him she like
straight up so the fact that they
these guys claim that gay and stuff like
that i mean you can't attack a man's
character
yeah and so he so he sued that dude for
10 mil defamation look at back there you
remember uh the
uh remember the titans remember when
sunshine got in there and it was like yo
let me know if you get
so that's a big deal so i mean i
remember we had uh when i was playing
basketball you don't believe me
i was in uh louisiana and this guy like
what was the school
west dale what's there where's dale
middleton high school middle school
middle school
i believe you played middle school ball
i play high school as well okay keep
going
bro okay i can't wait till this goddamn
time
so what happened all right so we had
this guy
like so we you know he was our center he
was a big guy for 8th grader
and he literally like bagged it you know
bag his butt down yeah like on purpose
he'd do like he's getting ghost
yeah posing but he's just like dude he's
like yeah when he talked trash talk
he was like yeah take you got a little
small dick and we used to push him and
he kept doing that he'd do that to the
other
team and then we just a fight broke out
and was like we'll play that gate
so when the other teams beat him up he
was like well [ __ ]
he gay you know that's how we take it
like so we didn't so y'all believed he
was gay
yeah and another team so we they jumped
them and because he kept talking trash
you didn't help me
out i mean i wasn't about to fight i had
to
listen i had like they beat him up
because they thought he was gay yeah
yeah but if you put the energy out there
like he was just playing around like you
know what i mean
like oh you got a small dick i can feel
it i was like man get the [ __ ]
yeah i mean i'm gonna just psych y'all
out
no no he was talking to that wasn't
really good but he'll do that in
practice
no he wasn't gay but he just just you
can't play like that you can't even play
like yeah you couldn't yeah at that time
yeah
nice serious yes but i was in louisiana
come on yeah
i mean yeah it's big down south that's
that's yeah cornell was like if
if i was somewhere else maybe be last
frowned upon he's like dude but
he's hollering at pittsburgh he's like
they do not play that man
he's like everybody treated me different
that's so like imagine not it's not true
like it's all made up he's like that's
why
he said the the someone when the uh
someone who worked for the steelers
called him was like hey man
i don't know if you see the news out
there but you know they're saying that
you're getting he didn't even know
he started laughing he's like who gives
a [ __ ] he's like everyone knows i [ __ ]
girls man
he's like no no dude it's getting
traction he's like yeah but it's not
real who gives a [ __ ]
he's like and then i got to the
pittsburgh steelers headquarters and
there's a pr person waiting out front
he's like what's up
she's like hey we need to figure this
out he's like figure what out yeah
she's like these rumors that you're gay
he's like what the [ __ ] is going on
right now [ __ ]
so how does that work like okay so like
obviously that dude did not have 10
million
so i don't know how that's gonna work
yeah how does that work like he gets 10
million
yeah he some kind of got a good
percentage of his money i don't know
either way that'll go to jail
either that'll go to jail you know
you've got to pay
oh so he probably has to pay like
information of character yeah that's a
big deal
that's a big [ __ ] deal it's just
put it like this look at the times we're
getting remember back then when when
delivered
i don't like men's anymore like i was
back when i used to sin
ah let's go into current events gin okay
hit us sad though
out of cornell stewart jersey and [ __ ]
oh he's a big-time steelers fan
well he's from university colorado oh
yeah alumni the buffs
alumni real real alumni really
not not three years
so these are cats since you can't be
here today getting a tattoo
fat that's that new money that's that
new money that's that new money
she said i got that doctor wu doing my
tattoo so i can't come in i was like
what
little uzi vert pierced his forehead
with a 24 million pink diamond
and they flashed it here 24 well i can't
play the music but
you see it let me see the video though
just okay 24 mil
[ __ ] uh you can get those you can get
those piercings like
so like uh they got being in the middle
of your forehead diamond you know
you have to put some brackets in there
he wasn't the first one so he's beefing
no you're not the first one to do that
so type in sauce walker he was the first
one to do this but then they go back to
a little weak
sauce walker he'll show you so he famous
he's like a houston he gets money
like a little drug dealer he's a rapper
though right so
he used the first person he showed on
his instagram how they did the surgery
and uh look that's that's his first one
right there right
so what he did is and his was like what
10 mil or something like that 10 million
dollars what are you guys getting all
this money
well again he's just like we're assuming
it's real but whatever
but again so they're beefing over like
putting implanted diamonds on their face
like you know what i mean
which is dumb you're running out of
money you know you have a bad idea man
sounds horrible but they they lay down
you gotta have a whole operation
yeah basically like he showed it on his
instagram yeah life goes kind of like a
surgery yeah go to salsa
sausage yeah sauce sauce walker
kind of sauce twins yeah yeah sauce
that's good too that's even better can
we stay focused
and he he shows him getting that yeah he
goes down yep he's
underneath the table no why's he have
all these chicks oh because he's a i
mean he's a
sausage sauce walker hey sauce sauce
boss
sausage that one no no because you can
see it on his face going on he's still
on his face
he bit it he did it a minute ago he'll
show it to you oh go up go up go up
go up go up is that one diamond yeah i
think that's
the winning flashing right there in the
middle in the middle
can you play it i think he has music
it's just it's taking a little time
because it's like a long video oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i'm not the one
[Music]
[Music]
250 thousand dollars that's probably the
right price
the one next to it chin yeah let's see
the next one go the one with the little
diamond yeah
go that one yeah exactly 250
nah he must have took it down he was
getting a lot of slack uh flack from it
because they was like yo why would you
they show you can't really show it he
was underneath the table you had to go
under
and they put it on his feet like damn
that was nasty but he still drip god
i'm the richest he still bleeds from his
cheek
from that's a bad idea man they can't
end well yeah
they can't age well you know him god
damn not him a little uzi
this guy is fantastic
[Laughter]
that's his girl yeah that doesn't even
look real though are you serious jim
it doesn't change
just like that sauce bunny right there
he got his bunnies
oh you got bunnies yeah look at that
right there all right chan we're good
okay that was a
i'm sorry but yeah it's all good it's a
crazy current event though yeah
so he's saying he's 24 mil 10 million so
44 is insane
they're beefing so now that created beef
like man i was the first one
and little uzi uh shot a picture of
little b it was like nah a little b was
the first one but
of course a little bit spent like over a
million to get that implant
so now that little uzi was like yeah i'm
not the first one
uh sauce boss where the [ __ ] you kind of
sausage
saucy was the first one he was like uh
cool yeah
and he was like bro he's clearly he's in
a different tax bracket yeah
they're both terrible ideas but yeah i
feel you yeah but the
crazy like that's how you start beef now
like in the rap game that's how soft it
is
like mel's the first one to do it now
they like they have words for each other
diamonds in your first huh why would it
just battle it what
battle it out not in the street i'm
talking about a rapper
yeah like make a track who does that
these days yeah
everybody comes from eminem all the
[ __ ] time remember eminem killed uh
mgk
kind of mg mgk's uh it's devil thing
wasn't bad
it wasn't bad i'd say he's out of all
the people that have like clapped back
at eminem
he's probably he's probably like the
better one i think he comes from that
world though
i love eminem but remember his lyrics
were like you know
killing his girlfriend and it's beating
up his mom and then now he's all woke
and anti-trump
i know it's weird you can you can get
into the i can't get to knowing you go
back to rome
it's just weird that you know like you
know and you didn't
when you were in the late 90s early
2000s like it was all like
murder and hitting [ __ ] and all
crazy [ __ ] and then now it's like super
anti-trump and like
this is just a weird move were you a fan
of him yeah i'm still a fan
i did that pose for him for free
[Laughter]
this one this one first a defendant
flirted with a judge
oh have you seen this judge so what
happened yeah she's bad i saw that she
is
damn it i can't i thought you had to be
older to be a judge [ __ ]
hold up superman on page 26
all right i'm good sir how are you
you is so gorgeous i just have to tell
you you're gorgeous
thank you mr lewis all right mister all
right mr lewis
will get you everywhere do you say i
love you yeah
finds probable cause on count one
burglary occupied that was it
she's like very cool so you go to prison
right you give a damn she's like yeah no
[ __ ] anyways
so not impressed man it's super bad i
don't get that damn sweetie
you got ig i know
i know i'm going to prison but listen
shoot her shoot come visit me
come visit me you know richard ramirez
got married in prison yeah
all the women love him oh yeah we got a
bunch of groupons yeah
i would say best looking serial killer
is that the best looking judge like i've
been to court
and i'm not usually judges are really
old
usually old white men she's very cute or
judged judy
old white people or old white women or
old white men or like
really
yeah so you're going 27 to live
let me just she's so pretty she's cute
what does she mix with
oh look at them eyes why do they get
that weird i don't know it's like green
screen
green starbucks
oh [ __ ] up she's all this episodes
brought to you by starbucks [ __ ] 2021
that's the best i can find
promo code hot judge anyways her name is
uh it says a top what does that say your
name on top uh jim
i mean i saw pictures of her later
that's why i didn't want to bring him up
she looks a lot better on
tab but this right here tab oh you've
seen let me see the other pictures chin
what's her last name looking at her
yeah let us be the justin
all right here you guys go hold on hold
on there you go
yeah she's super yeah there you go yeah
oh yeah she's bad how old is she but she
looks a lot cuter in the than the thing
though
you got to be honest right she looks
maybe she's not even photogenic i don't
think anybody looks
cute in that resume i look ugly over
zoom she looks really cute man really
cute right here no she's a baddie she's
bad
she's a pretty girl i mean if i wouldn't
be put away i want her to put me away
thank you i
listen her convictions sound convincing
too yeah i'm like oh yeah
yeah you know if i lie i deserve it
thank you thank you she flirted back too
she goes
flattery will get you everywhere no so
she did play along the player will get
everywhere uh
but not here but not here but with a
judge so you can get 15 years to life
well i appreciate you for seeing what
else you got she was like a five
thousand
five thousand dollar bond that she gave
him that's cool although she showed love
too
yeah yeah she's pretty man all right do
you guys know who this guy is yeah
alfred peyton yeah
um apparently sons sons he's the same
oh he used to have these he used to have
these like blocks and then i'm so glad
oh yeah you said the wild locks yeah
that uh he played orlando yeah
kansas orlando yeah new york they're
saying that fan
a lot of fans are saying that this has
to be his burner account because of all
the posts he's doing
i can totally see payton go for 25 plus
tonight and shun the haters
i don't laugh this hard hearing a brick
man another game but this time new york
has to let effort control the game or
let him get comfortable then results
would speak for themselves
and then it says always pick your
brothers up you just tell that to nick
fans
wow so elf has a bad assist day and
you y'all post this see this is fake
stuff i'm talking about
i'm not uh i am not alfred payton you
guys got to chill this could make him
look bad
how do you want to reset your password
[ __ ]
l g ah yeah it could be just a super fan
though
could be well his first mistake his
first mistake listen for creating a
burner account you're doing it all wrong
all right what you got to do you can't
have that uh uh icon
you got to have like an american flag
something go in there you got something
different
right you gotta have like a picture of
yeah knicks fan yeah
no hell no just say say like damn man i
always have to work during the games
yeah cause you're playing
came back and nick sloshing my head all
okay is you won't win if we're playing
shoots like seven times
that's what i'd love to see man up for
controlling the game i'll score that
this dude's
[Applause]
[Music]
katie had a good one yeah he got caught
he's like talking [ __ ] to like a 12 year
old
but but skip bayless he was just like
arguing and trolling like really no he's
getting kills with himself right
man no his were when he got caught he
didn't know he was using his account he
thought he was using the bird account
man i think skip man is the smartest guy
out there i love this show
and then people like yo bro this is from
your account oh
he deleted that delete it damn
dummy he's like i think skip bailey says
great points he's so [ __ ] smart man
handsome too you ask me
[ __ ] that i'm not making a burner
account
you got this one brandon uh army the
camel handler claims he's being kink
shamed by the internet
but women have hit him up saying i can't
eat pieces of them wow
yeah so here's what's [ __ ] up some
friend leaked their text combo
what do you mean a friend of his who
he's texting about this situation
leaked the cop how though he got his
phone or something no his friend
screenshot
screenshot their text and sent it to the
media yeah what a [ __ ] man
but army was saying that all these women
are like hitting them up now
and i told you i have girlfriends who
once this came out like that's so
[ __ ] hot
i was like really what him talking about
[ __ ] cut off your toes and [ __ ]
i was like i don't really need my feet
click on that chin yeah
it's weird though right like women are
super into it what
so pleasure choking stone just the point
where they're about to hold on
i guess they they have like a whole slew
of his tax it gets pretty graphic
this is my thing though it's like he
hasn't
he hasn't done it he's just that's just
what gets him he's just talking
yeah like he's turned on by the thought
of it
but he's lost all his jobs man every job
he's lost
um yeah it's wild
and they keep begging him on oh play
that gym let me know that
wait for the commercial i'll see see
what they did there
just the sickest dog in the world i'm
getting doctors don't even know
what's going on no one knows this thing
is about
it's all just a show whatever i'm john
how you doing
oh you know just another day in paradise
except for like you know it's not
paradise like it's more like
the world's fun apart yeah
so what's wrong with this why didn't
they play her [ __ ]
well she's just actually texting and
he's answering through the voice but the
purple is her oh yeah
right so they only go to armies
what did she say to him i don't know see
that's that [ __ ]
weird right yeah it is so hard
i'm i i think i'm going to be in bed for
a while nothing wrong with that
nothing he's saying it's like yeah yeah
nothing he's saying is bad
orgasm i want you to tell me how it felt
like how strong each was
how long it lasted yeah freak now he's
free
don't forget so you have to tell me
everything okay he's solely
he's he's lost his crazy even with that
his voice sounded he's fine he comes
from so much money his family's like
elite elite he's a rich oil
that's a good girl tell me about it
voice note or video
what are these what are they saying to
him because you
you she had voice memos to him too yeah
yeah i need to look more into it because
i don't know uh
so let me get this straight since they
leak the dms
more girls are coming out like i want
yeah they're like oh i like that
okay what if what if army told the girl
to leak the dms
because he's like yo he can't because it
hurts he's not gonna work again dude
he's [ __ ] he has a show coming out
with disney and disney's trying to
decide what they're gonna do
here's a movie coming out but he filmed
it like two years ago it's just now
coming out
the thing about condom from it and like
trying to edit it
it's just not good man god damn he's
kind of [ __ ]
is that his girl yeah it's his ex
yeah okay well strolling draw man i
would say uh
i was thinking about how perfect your
tits are i tried to come up with a chest
harness that
had a handle in the middle of your
perfect tits oh
and a quick knot oh sure
those pictures from my old snapchat you
can do better haters
clapping back i like that army all right
so
yeah that one's tough man
yeah because it's not a crime being
committed
no yeah fantasy everyone's like it's
everything's consensual
yeah so has he done anything like that
has he
actually no we don't know carving a into
the girls like
leg like leg hyper thigh but again she
let him do it yeah
like he was all consensual so they
dropped so he's gonna be canceled
because of fetish yeah like that's so
crazy
i don't know that's why i'm crazy man
this is dangerous so now because that's
what gets him off and you guys think
it's weird
he gets canceled yeah he can't be in
movies anymore
that's [ __ ] weird he didn't commit a
crime then you know yeah if
it now now if he's doing like holding
them down and you know and they didn't
want to do it yeah yeah
it's like a different difference i'm off
this yeah yeah but if he's like that
they're playing along we're just talking
about it and they're playing along with
it
and that's what gets them you know yeah
he can get cancelled from that basically
that's what's happening well
like the lack of details for [ __ ] delete
that episode when i
i told him i mean my girl did the ball
gag delete that no that's fine
[Laughter]
at this point i don't know now marilyn
manson is a little different
huh uh uh yeah marilyn manson tastes a
little different yeah
his seems pretty bad yeah so many women
came out but his uh his
ex came out and said that he for seven
years you know dida vontis that girl
that does the what's it called
burlesque yeah that kind of stuff she
said that she never that does not sound
like him at all she was with him for
seven something years
yeah marilyn manson came out it was like
anything i've ever done has been
consensual
like all this stuff coming out i have no
clue what to say that's what i'm saying
i like how like how are people getting
away just by saying [ __ ]
and then that's the [ __ ] yeah that's
it that's the that's the that's it
right there you you read the romance and
account you're like [ __ ] it's bad
i didn't get into these but there's no
it's just their words versus hits
yeah yeah but i don't know i don't know
how you canceled dude if you have zero
so
where's his chance to [ __ ] defend
himself then it's just him be like no
that never happened in the public eye
yeah that's it yeah and the public
he's probably like of course his agency
his agency dropped him his
his record label dropped him off i mean
he'd be
fine just maybe he's also 52 he's made
more money than [ __ ] satan at this
point
yeah it's just yeah it's just weird like
i mean i don't know you want to believe
the person obviously you don't
you don't want to just rule them out if
that's you know that's what they're
saying but at the same time
if there's nothing there's like yeah
like what like how can we take this
first
process where it's them versus him and
we get this out in court of law
and then let a jury decide yeah but you
can't be guilty by social media
by social yeah social media is not the
[ __ ] judge no
i know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go to
my call
[Laughter]
uh speaking of canceling uh we we even
brought to scott many
times in the show morgan wallin have you
heard about his most recent counseling
yeah
waylon waylon is it wayland is it whalen
i think wayland jennings and morgan
wallin
yeah there you go but he was i guess he
was drunk
and he called one of his his own crew
someone
called the n-word yeah the n-word but i
watched the video he's like drunk
they're playing around he says the
n-word
he calls he goes oh don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's like oh come on you [ __ ]
get this [ __ ] n-word uh but he's
dropped by
everybody now his record label and
definitely
won all the cma awards they can't win he
was killed he's not even oh he's the
biggest
country i was loving his music yeah yeah
it's just
okay i see where you're at almost like
it's almost kind of self-sabotaged
because
he already had that issue with the
saturday snl where he's making out with
the girls during covert his wife was
pregnant or
giving birth in a hospital and then this
happens like dude you're getting too
wild
he needs to get out of here he's
watching yeah he's going to oh did he
get out of his own way
but you you know how you got how this
video came about his neighbor
his neighbor being all out his neighbor
filmed him and then sent it to the media
27 being loud he was drunk [ __ ] with
his buddies
[ __ ] do you guys want to watch the video
you guys
hey actually hey y'all
[Music]
i think that's all he said he come out
with a statement yeah yeah what do you
say he's like i gotta do better i can't
use that language um
do you guys black men do you think you
should be canceled for that
that's what i want to find out from you
guys too justin bieber said it about did
that offend you malik
uh not really but again i'll probably
get
here's the thing if we know rap songs i
know
a lot of people don't skip over the n
word you know let's be honest
let's be honest yeah that's right it's
impossible but again
if he if someone call if he called me a
[ __ ] ass
like i feel uncomfortable saying it
because i know our fan base but i'm
saying if he said the n word to me i'm
like man
what'd you say drunk or not that'd be
different yeah be different he said to
another
black man that's a dude yeah but he
should get his face stomped
exactly but he said it to a white boy
but what's weird so scroll up
you know and then people go on it's
black history keep scrolling up
so when you go the hate runs deep so she
is a black
uh female country artist as well so
she's feeling a lot she says she felt a
lot of it
in the industry because you know there's
not many people so
hers is like i'm not in her she's yeah
i'm not in her shoes but i don't know
she said he shouldn't get cancelled
though he should learn something
i don't think he's learning get changed
i think canceling people yeah
you're making the problem worse yeah you
make the problem worse because what like
a person doesn't get the chance to learn
you know what i mean like or like
understand or like grow from a [ __ ]
situation
he's he's he's also 20 also
drunk young bro not a big excuse for him
but the guy shouldn't lose his [ __ ]
arrow pull like this if he said one n
word he uses losing his career over that
i know he's saying a lot of them in this
crib now
yeah it is tough like
yeah it's tough though i mean yeah but
again
i got i don't know this mickey uh guyton
put and lastly i do not believe in
canceled culture watching anyone fall
from grace's terrible thing
people must all be given a chance to
change morgan must feel the weight of
his words but completely throwing
someone away is detrimental to anyone's
mental health it's great that she did
that
yeah yeah and i i appreciate i
appreciate that like
that i think that's right i
yes they're taking him off the radio and
he won't be up for a cma
i would i would imagine his ticket sales
are pretty strong
right i was like people are still gonna
bump i was about to say they probably
love you
i don't feel different about him like i
think he made a horrible mistake and
it's [ __ ]
stupid but i don't think he i don't
think he's racist
no i don't know i don't know the guy but
i don't know the guy either i don't
think he's racist like i've been around
people before that said it white friend
and well she's like god damn come on
dude yeah but i'm not like oh he's
to them i think those guys that have
said around me it's more like
you know [ __ ] around yeah maybe they
got too comfortable you know what i'm
saying
but those guys have said it like they're
not inherently
race like they're not gonna march for
the kkk how many times i've seen dudes
drop it at an open mic
yes all the [ __ ] they try to they try
to put it like oh i'm not saying to eat
or i'm gonna say
they they have a bit about it but
they'll have a bit about and they'll
just yeah they'll say it they'll say it
but again they say it all the time so
again yeah now if it was in
like a racist like set like this er
like if it's the hard er in the context
like
like if they said you oh like i'm sure
there's comments to go brendan's doing a
show with these two
ninjas now but with er that then you're
talking about inherently racist people
yeah that's 100 yeah 100
but but again that that i think he was
just talking to his buddy
i had he he's so drunk i don't know but
he was black like dude what do you mean
now he's saying
you have to sit down you don't have to
sit down maybe yeah yeah
if he was what i'm saying maybe morgan
gets drunk black out and becomes black
and he's like man take care of that
[ __ ] ass ninja you know i mean and then
i think i don't know you just i don't
know him i don't yeah i don't know i
don't know i don't that's the thing i
don't know him so it's like
it's hard for me to say like what i
truly feel honestly yeah the whole
cancer thing
i don't think he should get canceled
like i yeah i think yeah he
should be able to have the chance he's
also 27 28 it's like you can't make any
mistakes
yeah you're going to take them off radio
mm-hmm it's it's
i don't know if that's the move yeah but
we just talked about different times but
but also let the
let the public decide have the point
where we decide let the public decide if
he can be unready or not
we'll see the problem he's selling
records still let's see if he has music
streaming
he'll still he'll still sell records
i don't listen super he's super talented
yes stupid talented
he's stupid talented but i think yeah
it's the biggest oh yeah you said he won
all the awards sometimes
he would have not now oh [ __ ] who's that
black girl who's that black girl
she's she's a country artist and she
said she faced racism
in the industry and she's like sure
she's like you know imagine dms that she
gets like you know from really really
saying it now now again in her shoes i
get how people will feel like man man
[ __ ] him
you know what i mean but i get that but
i don't know dude you know what i mean
yeah i don't i don't know i don't know
do you guys get racist dm still hell
yeah still no no ever since
that little um that little that little
situation was talking about jacob blake
they still do i'm like but i was a
couple of episodes ago
i'm like yeah oh yeah one time we were
sitting at dinner
and i got some when you sit next to me
yeah yeah
yeah it happens but we know they're out
there but again yeah that's out there it
doesn't affect me
yeah but i'm saying for him i think that
like honestly getting dropped from the
label too fast but again i get what
she's saying like let him learn from it
yeah let him learn
she said it the best i think yeah she
said everything how it feels how it
hurts her everything but then
she doesn't even think i think of it
like this like
what if what if i didn't give my dad a
chance like he he did all this [ __ ]
make mistakes made a lot of mistakes
wasn't in my life you know what i mean
he's not and now he's you know he was
doing good he or now he's doing good
he learned you know and he you know we
reach out to each other
imagine if i was just like no you you
had this [ __ ] that you did back in
the 80s you missed it yeah
it's like but like since i've accepted
him in my life
look what the [ __ ] it's become you know
what i mean so like i couldn't imagine
just
canceling him out because of some [ __ ]
that like from back in the day like that
i don't know
that a neighbor recorded when you're
drunk let me ask you a question i don't
agree with it but i actually
shouldn't lose it yeah i don't i don't i
don't yeah no one no one's agreeing
remember
what it was like i'm glad there's no
ninjas here so i'm like different
because he knows what he's doing it's
calculated
then he's actually racist a drunk night
out he gets out of an uber
hammered calls his buddy the n-word he's
like and he
knows that's not gonna be on tv or
broadcasted i don't know man
let me ask you this if he was walking
down the street you saw that instance
right he's drunk with his neighbor and
he was like yo
you walking right and you jus he gotta
know her drunk say uh
you said what he says what would you do
to me or chappelle no no just like
you walking you're you're not involved
in the situation i think oh what is what
a [ __ ]
i keep going i wouldn't even stop dude
exactly i just want to put in an
audience what would you do
i wouldn't stop when chan what would you
do i'll probably just look at him like
the two of us were walking down the
street in nashville and someone was like
oh look at look at shaw with those two
well that's er's
then out something yeah what'd you say
exactly what johnny
[Laughter]
yeah it is weird cause like i mean it's
different times i mean yeah and like
growing up where i grew up like i mean
arizona like predominantly white like
you know you hear dudes
white dudes drop it all the [ __ ] time
and i i go i would just say
listen i'm not gonna sit here and fight
you or or come at you
crazy right now but i go you're lucky
you're standing next to me
you might not get me so you're getting a
little too comfortable yeah some other
dudes
that's what i'm saying and i usually
they they go oh [ __ ] i should probably
stop saying
i guarantee that's usually like i
guarantee you morgan wallin wouldn't
talk like around you guys
no no no it's different energy but again
you probably like us louisiana bro
you're cool
you can just tell like man you seem like
he's deal knows it well he seems like
he's probably like he's just a cool kid
like based off of like
you know probably listen to hip hop yeah
i try and get a diamond no he doesn't
know so he's a dope ass dude yeah he was
also friends with david duke
hold on now i didn't know that
i've been waiting for this go ahead and
read it so that's that's lamarro's
opponent
this is aaron carter [ __ ] look at his
face too
that pose is just so depressing well
both
are yes it looks like a real shitty
fight promotion when you're
looking at lamar odom's [ __ ] hand i
know he's all
don't give us a fight pose day hold up
and why is this why does he have a
[ __ ] mock turtleneck on why wouldn't
you take your shirts off
yeah that's that j job also this is uh
all this
is is it it's money for drugs for both
of them yeah
it's important to have the purse should
be heroin where are they going what is
that bunny rant
oh my god oh this is not real oh my god
no one wants to see that no i don't
this i think lamar is gonna knock him
out yeah no one wants too tall he's too
tall
no one's gonna pay for this who wants to
pay for that people want to watch
because it's a car crash
it's a car wreck you know oh my god i'll
i'll definitely find an illegal
streaming
yeah no that was [ __ ] for that it's a
nightmare
they have to release this for free look
at lamar yeah they're
they're going to charge for it three
rounds three minutes that's fine
don't hear what uh stupid you gotta hear
what he says
he needs some serious mental health yeah
what's up yeah did he come out as gay
aaron carter yeah um i just wanted to
tell you
i'm really excited to be fighting the
lamar odom
this is a crazy matchup i mean it's like
david and goliath uh
he's six foot seven i'm six one so it's
going to be kind of crazy uh i'm talking
about somebody i just want to let you
guys know that i'm not supposed to live
he's every bit of this he was a powerful
an entertainer
um a singer a dancer i'm also a fighter
so i i grew up street fighting and oh
you know i'm really looking forward to
it dude you grew up and your brother was
one of the biggest
band members the harder they fall so
lamar
i'll see you there bro all right
you did not grow up i can't [ __ ] take
this what's this
this is uh damon feldman does he have
any relationships to any feldman's
no filming okay
chad filming no i don't know there's a
there's a felon in bkfc
i think there's a felon in there yeah
and then there's also another i don't
know
let me see this himself in this fight
yeah so this is this is the main guy
that did the big
celebrity boxing matches before kevin
hart in that movie
you are the founder you are the creator
of celebrity boxing and you have a huge
event coming up
at the showboat casino in atlantic city
you have lamar
odom the former nba star fighting
stepping in the boxing ring but we don't
know
who lamar is fighting yet and i know
you're about to
make this announcement here so who is
the six foot 10 inch lamar
odom former nba star fighting at the
showboat casino
well he's going to take on six feet 185
pound
one and only music star aaron carter so
they're going to get it on alan carter
somebody said alan carter
alan carter we really thought about who
it was a lot of people got in touch
uh it's gonna be a shot it's gonna be a
showdown man one
you're both fighters but uh aaron has
boxing experience
lamar's an athlete and uh it just has
potential to be one of the biggest
celebrity fights of all time
now uh have any idea about how many
rounds it's going to be
length of the rounds have those details
been well worked out yet
so it's gonna be a war man where they
were in a knockout there's no doubt
because it's only three
one and a half minute rounds that's
that's that's the legal rules of
celebrities i bet you there's no
knocking i have like my
is not to do that yeah it takes skill to
knock someone out
sometimes you get lucky with a rabbit
punch but it's like with gloves on
does damon feld help filming have a
history in like boxing or something
this is like some drinking oh it's just
like it's just a promoter guy
this is a [ __ ] joe yeah it just looks
like a promoter guys get your money i
don't want to see him chen what else you
got
sp uh tonight uh paige vance amp fights
bare knuckle boxing oh yeah
guess who's uh walking out the girl
guess who's walking oh
little brows little brows yeah like dude
knuckles hit me up do you think it's a
good look if i rap and during the
walkouts i'm like i don't know if the
best look
but it's something dude yeah i would say
what's that
go for castle i don't know he does
yeah he already does something for them
is that it that's it man that's a [ __ ]
show but i will watch that car crash
what a nightmare i don't know again the
purse should just be a bunch of heroin
yeah or two free nights at the bunny
ranch ooh
that's not bad that's not bad that's not
bad at all [ __ ] i'll fight all right i'm
taking my ass not to the bunny ranch but
the tampa improv february 26
27th two shows february 26 on a friday
two shows february 27th of saturday
tampa florida this month february 26th
to 27th
get your tickets now f-a-t-k-z dot-com
i'll also be posting on my instagram
story and wall and on twitter so you can
get them there
and then miami florida florida again yay
miami florida
march 25th to the 27th miami florida
miami improv
lots of florida uh f-a-t-k-z dot com
for those as well tampa you're on the
clock miami up next
get em chappelle will be in poland city
city yeah
february 2015 for him or chappelle
lacy.com
your kansas city the 25th through the
27th
and then austin texas i'm excited for
march 5th through the 6th at the
vulcan gas company that'd be fun man i
know
let's do it all right get them tickets
we're out malik b
karuchi broke up with victor cruz i'm
shocked but not as shocked as these nike
shots
yeah like those are um
got my vans on but they look like
sneakers chapelle lacy baby
all my favorite punk videos shout out to
brian johnson dude brian
studios yeah those are cool you made
these man
the [ __ ] with a heavy yeah these are
shoes these are shoes of the day man
you know what it is take back homie
[Laughter]
my man can't jump reference what you
know about them porsche dunks
classic porsche dunks support
what's up man let me get though you
can't have a porsche not have matching
dunks
get off my dick i don't want to do
my shoes stop everybody stop everybody